emanuel macro ni angela merkel dos
líderes con una preocupación compartida
por la futura relación del continente
con washington este viernes mantuvieron
conversaciones en su primera reunión
desde que joe biden asumió la
presidencia estadounidense los dos han
discutido sus puntos de vista sobre el
caso de alexéi navalni el mayor crítico
del kremlin que ha sido condenado a dos
años y ocho meses en una prisión rusa y
se pronunciaron con un mensaje firme y
unido
con respecto al asunto de navalny
condenó con la mayor firmeza de
principio a fin lo que ha ocurrido desde
su detención pasando por su
envenenamiento hasta hoy la expulsión de
los diplomáticos alemanes polacos y
suecos una decisión de rusia
mckeon y merkel también abordaron otras
cuestiones urgentes a las que se
enfrenta la unión europea defendieron el
vacilante programa del bloque de
adquisición de vacunas contra el
coronavirus con merkel diciendo que la
unión europea necesitaba aumentar las
capacidades de producción hasta ahora la
vacuna no se ha puesto a disposición de
los 27 estados
por igual apoyamos el trabajo de la
comisión y de su presidenta
úrsula von der leyen pero como estado
miembro también nos implicamos muy
activamente para aprovechar todas las
posibilidades de acelerar la producción
de esta vacuna duran unos siles además
en la agenda de este viernes proyectos
claves de defensa lanzados por ambos
países desde 2017 esto así como un
impulso a la participación de alemania
en las operaciones militares en el sahel